okay hello everyone so we are back for
an
episode of science and technology QA for
kids and others and we have been having
a bit of discussion about sort of making
science fiction real and we can continue
that today I see we already have some
questions saved up from last time and
maybe there are new ones I'm not sure
where they've come from but let me start
off with the first one from Einstein
Bonn Rembrandt considering the Star Trek
Universal Translator what size samples
of an unknown language will be needed to
begin to understand it that's an
interesting question
I mean if we look at kind of the history
of trying to understand languages where
there weren't any speakers around knew
what those languages meant it's an
interesting history so I mean the first
thing to understand is most of the
languages that are not lost we know what
they are because there are people who
speak them or speak derivatives of them
so for example Latin we Latin was
preserved in particularly the Catholic
Church and other places and although
it's mutated over the course of a couple
of thousand years it hasn't mutated so
much was also taught in schools for a
long time even classical form if we look
at something like Babylonian you know
Akkadian something like that it was much
less clear what all those canary form
marks that people are excavated in from
in from Babylon meant it wasn't clear
what the hieroglyphics that were found
in Egypt meant and most of these things
were decoded because there was a a
parallel text that existed so in the
case of hieroglyphics there was the
rosetta stone which is a physical stone
that's in the British Museum these days
that listed on it three languages and it
listed the same proclamations written in
three languages one of which was the
hieroglyphic language of Egypt and so
that gave sort of a big leg up on
decoding things I think come
akkadian was decoded as a result of a a
big inscription that existed somewhere
him was now Iran I think that I think
was put on put up by I think that was
the famous inscription of a King Darius
that Tim starts with you know I am
Darius King of Kings you know the
greatest ever type thing I think it's
the thing that was which there's a good
take off in the Shelley poem called I
was a man use that as a favorite for
some of us who like constructing things
in the world because it's it features
this some it's sort of concept is this
giant statue that was erected in some
somewhere and sort of the empire that it
was associated with crumbled and now the
statue is sitting in the desert
somewhere and all there is is some I
think it has in the moments you know two
vast and trunkless legs of stone so it's
just the legs are left and on the on the
inscription at the bottom it's you know
I am I think I was a man dias which i
think is Ramses the second king of kings
it says look on my works ye mighty and
despair and I think the point moans with
you know there's just sand everywhere so
in other words it's kind of a that
particular one is about some you know
you may build this sort of great Empire
and statue and so on but eventually time
catches up and all that stuff is a
desert we can we can hope that our
current civilization will will persist
better but in any case the the thing
that you know in terms of translation of
languages the the number one one way
that one learns about how to translate
something like an ancient language is
through the existence of these parallel
texts that what happens to find now in
modern times when one is dealing with
machine translation systems there's been
a lot of progress made in the last
probably five years in neural networks
for machine translation kind of learning
from examples how to translate things I
mean it's worth mentioning that in the
history of artificial intelligence there
was a big initiative in the nineteen
sixties to try and do machine
translation to try and automatically
translate from from one language to
another and actually the illustrative
it's sort of interesting piece of
history the one of the primary causes of
the initiative was during the Cold War
also standoff between the US and Soviet
Union and Russia and so on the there was
sort of a at some point there was that
kind of a you know a hot line installed
between the presidents of those of those
countries you know just in case somebody
launched a missile he could call the
other one and say well whoops it was a
mistake or or not as the case may be
but um one of the things that was a big
concern was oh there be some meeting
between the episode of the the pooh-bahs
the American poobahs the Soviet poobahs
and there would you know the Americans
would speak English the Soviets would
speak Russian and gosh they couldn't
understand each other and somebody would
have to translate and there was kind of
a a big concern maybe the interpreter
who was doing the translation as a human
between between these groups would say
the wrong thing and it would start World
War three and so people had the bright
idea gosh let's take the human out of
Luke and let's instead have a machine
translate between you know English and
Russian or something so that no mistake
is made now it's kind of amusing looking
back on it that that was kind of the
concept because in fact we know that
machine translation is much more fraught
with with absurd misunderstandings than
than typical human translators would be
but back in the early 1960s kind of the
idea was this is going to be one of the
big use cases for artificial
intelligence is let's avoid any
possibility of a misunderstanding
in diplomatic translate
so to speak okay so in modern times when
we see I don't know the translation I
don't know Google Translate or any of
these other services that does automatic
translation the what is now done it's
fairly recent thing is that that
translation is done using neural
networks and the idea is you give it a
bunch of samples of of of translations
and it will then extrapolate from those
it will then deduce from the the
examples it seen to deal with the
particular piece of text you've given it
so what are those samples come from
so those samples have come from parallel
texts in the case of machine learning
instead of one rosetta stone or one
inscription from you know Darius the
great or whatever one's dealing with
billions of words of documents that
exist sort of in parallel and one of the
big sources for European languages is
the European Union which for for it's
for better or worse takes pretty much
every official document and translates
it into all the languages of the
European Union and so that has generated
like billions of words of parallel texts
that may be legalistic sounding text but
nevertheless they are in parallel
between English and French and German
and Italian and so on and so on and so
on maybe they'll stop using English now
now that Britain is outside of the EU
I'm not sure I kind of doubt it I think
it's become a pretty standard generic
language for many folks um okay so
that's a source of parallel text there's
some other sources the peril texts and
the world another one there's a there's
a consortium that collects computer
manuals and documentation that have been
translated by companies that make
operating systems and you know the
apples and Microsoft's in this world and
so on have been translated through human
effort into many different languages and
people have collected that corpus of
translations and again that's used for
machine translation but these are very
large corpuses and that those corpuses
are used to to be able to train and
you're on that to say a
okay feed it in a piece of French it
will kind of try and make a parallel
piece of English of its own sort of
remembering oh I've seen a piece of sort
of French that looks a bit like that and
it was translated into English this way
so now I'll translate it that way myself
now so that's kind of the in a sense the
you don't really have to have a true
understanding of the meaning of the
French document you just have to know I
saw a document that looked like this the
force and I can translate it like this
again okay so now you ask the question
what about a sort of completely a.m.
language how do we know what it means
well it's hard to know the you know the
way that we might know where it means is
the same way that that the children
learn language which is they they see a
correlation between a word that said and
something that exists in the world or
something that happens in the world you
know somebody points to it and they say
cat and then you can sort of start to to
learn the the kind of the correlation
between between the word cat and the
object a cat and you know when children
learn language they typically learn
nouns first because they're sort of
things you can point to
sometimes they learn verbs that are
actions that they can readily sort of
identify and then later things like
sentence structure develop and so on
it's now you know presented with sort of
an alien species
how would you learn its language well
you you need to have some way of having
an association between the thus the word
that said and the the thing that it
refers to so you need some you need
something which sort of points at this
or that um
now people have tried to you know in in
science fiction movies like contact like
a rival and so on people have tried to
portray sort of the process of
associating the familiar with the thing
that's in sort of an alien's language so
to speak
by the way it's not self-evident that
the language would exist in anything
like the same way as we perceive
language so for example what is language
language is an attempt to find what we
might think of as a symbolic
representation of the world that is you
know right now I'm looking at a certain
visual scene it has a you know a camera
lens in the middle of it it has a bunch
of other things in it somebody might say
well what are you looking at and I might
say I'm looking at a camera okay but
there's also a lot of other detail and
scene that I'm looking at but the part
of it that I might pick out
it's just that part that I can describe
with the word camera I could say well
it's a camera which has a lens with the
particular circumference and it has you
know this wire connected to it and has
this thing and that thing the other
thing you say well no I just want to
sort of zoom out and I just want to say
it's a camera and you know I don't know
what kind of camera it is it's you know
it's on some stand it son of this it son
of that there's a lot of detail but what
language does is it it abstracts away
from that detail and gives us sort of
symbolic representation of the thing
that is important to us that we want to
talk about I mean at some level you know
I could think of the image in my my
that's you know on my retina my brain
it's an array of pixel values it's like
there's this color that this position is
that color at that position and so on
but that's not what I will choose to
describe what I'll choose to describe is
this symbolic version that is abstracted
from all of that so language is all
about having generic words generic
symbolic things that describe large
classes of actual things in the world
like I just say it's a camera I don't
have to say which particular serial
number of camera etcetera etcetera
etcetera it's just this generic it's a
camera so that's that's sort of the
fundamental point of language now human
language has the feature that it is
fundamentally a one-dimensional thing
that is we we speak language one word in
front and then the next word and the
next word and then the next word we
could imagine that we have instead a
picture language where things are laid
out in two dimensions and where
everything is represented by diagrams
you know in some limited situations we
do have that but mostly our language is
this one-dimensional stream of sounds
words whatever it's another thing sort
of interesting about human language not
obviously shared by all all conceivable
symbolic representations of the world
another feature of human languages is
they all have nouns and verbs and
adjectives and things like that
not obvious why that should be the case
it's not obvious whether that came
because there was sort of an ancestral
language I mean we know that we look at
the tree of languages that have
developed you know there are big chunks
like indo-european is this whole group
of languages that gradually split up and
turn into many of the languages we know
but there are other languages with
different lineages and but they all have
nouns and verbs and adjectives and so on
they have different exotic ways of doing
for example word order like English is a
subject-verb-object word order language
where we say the cat what's a good
example um the cat ate the fish and Liam
so that is the cat subject ate verb the
fish object so not all languages work
that way we like Latin for example would
be you know the cat the fish ate Felix
kiss gaze oh gosh what is eaten Latin
drat it's been that's what happens after
50 years at the case what is eat I must
know must be gust gust it must be the
root that comes gustatory must be that
tongue must be the same root so I'm not
sure but anyway that the word order is
subject object verb in Latin and for
example people though I don't know when
person made up the Klingon language for
Star Trek it's just to be exotic they
made it an object subject verb language
there are actually a few objects subject
verb languages that exist among the the
5,000 or so extant languages that are
spoken on the earth but any case so
there
these sort of Universal features of
language that we have like the existence
of of nouns and verbs and so on not
clear how general that is to anything
one could imagine as a language I mean I
know in the construction of
computational languages that I've spent
a lot of my life on we don't quite have
the direct analog of nouns verbs
adjectives doesn't quite work that way
it's a little bit of a different way to
represent knowledge so that's that's
sort of different but then you know I
think I've talked before in these
sessions about the languages of animals
that's a sort of a cautionary tale for
our ability to understand other
languages that we've got you know the
cats and dogs and and other critters of
the earth and we don't know you know if
they have a true symbolic language we
don't really know what it is if they
have one if they can communicate that
way if that's the way their thought
processes work we don't really know
those things so so the original question
that was asked is sort of how much of an
alien language would you have to have to
be able to do a translation
unfortunately the language on its own is
not enough you need a parallel text you
need maybe the the alien language plus
the alien pointing at things like in the
arrival movie for example or or sending
pictures of things like in the contact
movie too to be able to sort of
associate kind of the the linguistic
form with the representation that's
given I think it's a very interesting
question I lots and lots more probably
that could be said about some sort of
what's needed to to understand the
language from scratch I mean I would say
again in in modern artificial
intelligence and machine learning that
sort of something a little bit like that
that's happening because you present a
machine learning system with lots of
examples let's say you're trying to make
a machine learning system and recognize
images you showed a picture of a cat you
showed a picture of an elephant actually
not sure that one picture of a cat you
show it 300 pictures of a cat 500
pictures of an elephant and from those
pictures it tries to generalize it
to say what are the essential features
of cattiness service big elephant nests
that that it can used when it's
presented with the new picture to decide
what whether it's a cat or an elephant
or whatever else it might be and in a
sense you can if you take apart the
neural network that was constructed by a
sort of learning from those pictures you
can identify certain elements of that
neural network and you could say the the
neural net has learnt some concepts its
distinguishing the first thing it does
to distinguish a cat from nelle ephant
is it figures out whether it has trunk
eNOS or not well we don't in our human
language particularly have a word for
you know the shape of the thing that
makes it plausibly have a trunk as
opposed to not have a trunk but it's
something that the machine learning
system might have recognized as the most
important distinguishing thing that
distinguishes that say cats from
elephants and it might have found the
sort of good symbolic representation of
that but that's something is happening
internal to its knowing that and it's
not something that we necessarily can
identify I mean one of the great uses of
language for us is there to very obvious
great uses of language for us the most
most obvious is communicating with other
people the most obvious is being able to
take those detailed thoughts that we
have turn them into some symbolic
representation that is that uses
primitives that are sort of general
enough that somebody else can understand
them I mean when I say camera I know
what that means and you know that what
that means we have this sort of shared
connection of knowing roughly what that
means now my version of camera might be
you know I might think of the cameras
that I saw when I was a kid which looked
very different from the cameras that
existed today so there's sort of
different shades of meaning but we all
have the same sort of basic
understanding of a thing that we call a
camera and that's a word in our language
that that we understand so you know one
use of language is this is this use of
being able to communicate
sort of abstracted concepts to other
people another use of language is purely
for us to think internally in our own
minds about things and people have long
argued in sort of philosophy to what
extent our thought processes are shaped
by our language and to what extent at
which thought processes shape our
language
I'm really very convinced that our
language shapes our thought processes in
many ways we can see that most clearly
with computational languages where you
know in in the language I've spent many
years building will from language the it
very much shapes my thought processes
the way that that's been built and
shapes the thought processes lots of
other people unlike for example my big
adventure recently in making great
progress in finding the fundamental
theory of physics that is really a
consequence of the shaping of my thought
processes through decades of working
with a non Wolfram language and without
that I really wouldn't have the the the
sort of the conceptual wherewithal the
conceptual framework to be thinking
about the kinds of things I'm thinking
about in terms of fundamental physics I
mean this has been seen before you know
in the invention of essentially
mathematical language mathematical
notation and their mathematical ideas
like calculus and so on these provided
essentially so description or frameworks
that made it possible to actually figure
things out in that case in science but
so so there's a sort of secondary role
of language which is this internal role
of the framework with which you think
about things and its primary role the
framework with which you use to
communicate with other people now when
it comes to an AI for example right now
the language that the AI is constructing
internally the sort of it's symbolic
description of the way that it
understands images and so on that is
primarily for the second purpose that's
primarily for it to think inside itself
it we haven't yet figured out really how
to take that intermediate layer and and
make it a something that can be used for
communication now part of the reason for
that is because language as we use it as
humans is a very social kind of thing
that is we all have to know what
word camera means or it's not useful to
use the word camera if only if there
were only five people in the world who
knew what that word meant
then great it will be okay for
communicating within that group of five
people but it wouldn't be a general
thing that we could use in our language
so anyway it's a interesting question
all right lots of lots of more questions
here um okay there's a there's a fun
question here I'll take first here is
the best way to profit from Mars
exploration the selling of intellectual
property gained from research done there
can you think of any other ways this is
an interesting challenge the question of
space exploration and sort of what its
economically good for what it's good for
in you know if we look at exploration of
the earth in past years I would say that
was a mixture of things I mean part of
the aspiration of the earth you know the
great explorers Columbus Cook you know
all these kinds of people um part of the
the exploration was just like let's go
figure out what's what exists on the
earth but there was often a subtext of
let's find good good stuff that we can
get from you know some other part of the
world and and and bring it back to sell
it and I think that that's you know
whether it was bringing you know gold
back from the new world or whether it
was things like that that was one one
sort of thing the other thing was you
know very here these days unfortunate
kind of piece of history you know things
like whaling you know can we go find
whales to to get oil from that was sort
of the before we knew about getting oil
out of the ground that was sort of the
source of oil for oil lamps and things
like this
and
it's a you know one had to go sort of
all over the earth to go go go find that
but but so you know a a common
motivation for exploration of the earth
was sort of finding new stuff that we
could bring back or even existing stuff
that we could bring back in larger
quantities to sort of the main place
where people were buying and selling
things and and then and then sell it
there was also a certain to a certain
extent there was a a concept of let's go
out and explore the world for the sake
of exploring the world now the subtext
of that honestly was the story that is
often repeated in basic research which
is if you you know some of that stuff
was done at the time of the Spanish
Empire or the British Empire and if you
are a government Empire
then going out and finding new stuff in
the world because you are the primary
economic power and if there's new stuff
generated the chances are it will fuel
your economy it makes sense as sort of a
monopoly so I mean in you know when when
AT&T in Bell Labs when that was sort of
the monopoly that ran the phone system
in the u.s. there was lots of kinds of
research in our Tronics and other things
many other areas where the primary
beneficiaries of that research would be
the phone system and so it made sense to
do basic research even though it wasn't
even though it wasn't specific to some
particular product because sort of
anything that advanced that would be
primarily a benefit to the sort of
monopolies that was operating in that
area and so that was a you know when
people were like in the case of the
British Empire and Spanish Empire or
whatever like let's go out and explore
the world it was partly with a subtext
of well you know if something new is
discovered will benefit from it um so
you know I think when it comes to space
exploration that there are challenges
there about you know what's the point so
to speak there's a certain point of you
know let's go and dump let's just go and
explore
for the sake of science and so on but
that you know in the end people's you
know the world's appetite for for
spending its resources on that is
somewhat limited you know I think that
people have hoped that I will be able to
mine things I like like asteroids are
pretty good for that because asteroids
have been sort of have accumulated large
amounts of different kinds of elements
you know you want gold there's probably
a golden asteroid out there probably has
vastly more gold than has easy to mine
from the crust of the earth because of
what it would do to gold as a as a
scarce
sort of economic resource if somebody
brought back a gold asteroid I don't
really know but you know the question of
so you know there's one thing is can you
go and can you mine things of course
mining is only useful if it isn't too
expensive to bring the stuff back that
you mind but then there's the question
of I mean I think that the more cynical
folk might say you know the the way to
fund at least some robotic lunar
missions is you know you sell the the
movie rights so to speak and that you
know it's basically a branch of the
entertainment industry and up to a point
that's possible but by the time you're
doing missions to Mars I don't think
that really works
um the I think it's too expensive to be
able to justify on the basis of any kind
of entertainment advertising sponsorship
type type type deal you just not enough
goods are sold around it to be able to
justify having a whole spacecraft in
Mars colony and so on
so the question that was asked here was
about intellectual property that is sort
of ideas that are discovered through
having a Mars colony um it's an
interesting question whether that would
happen I mean that certainly a hasn't
really happened in in in space so far in
you know Noah Thor bit a lot of things
were developed as part of the space
program
you know the Apollo missions in the
1960s to land people on the moon that
was a huge and very impressive kind of
rush
engineering project that just involved
just a lot of things had to be invented
to make that possible and I you know I
know even from my own experiences of
doing large engineering projects that
the force of getting the large
engineering project done creates a lot
of inventiveness and a lot of things get
get produced that are that go beyond the
specifics of that particular engineering
project that's exactly what happened
with the space program all kinds of
different funky things from freeze-dried
food to some extent to micro types
although that was probably about for
other reasons too were were the results
of the Apollo program in the 1960s and
that was that was more the development
of of inventions to support the process
of making in the case of what's being
asked here in the future of Mars colony
rather than you go to Mars and on Mars
the scientists there technologists there
invent new things there's there's that's
a that's an interesting idea that might
happen I don't know it's it's some I
don't think that the I don't know how
many you know how many patent filings
have been done where the address of the
inventor is Antarctica my guess is the
answer is well the interesting is easy
to look up but my guess is the answer
might actually be zero and so exactly
how that would play out on on Mars I'm
not sure okay um
oh boy so many interesting questions um
let's see um I was a claim here that
Latin had an arbitrator when when I
learnt it in school it was always
subject to object verb um
it's true that I think on inscriptions
I've seen other things so that may be
that may be correct um let's see okay
there's a question from Dominica um do
you have advice for teenagers who want
to discover a new kind of science the so
who wants her for example make big
discoveries in science or whatever else
yeah I mean I probably do have some
suggestions um I suppose my first
suggestion is the very idea that you can
discover new things is not self-evident
I mean in in I think most of us are born
with the idea that we can discover new
things but when you go to school the
main thing you learn about is things
that are already been discovered that
you're supposed to learn about in other
words there is an existing body of
knowledge and a lot of what's involved
in school is his this body of knowledge
now go learn this and the concept that
new knowledge could be created is much
less obvious and in fact this sort of a
question of a lot of knowledge has been
accumulated in these few thousand years
of our civilization and for the sake of
kind of leading a productive life it's
worth knowing a bunch of that knowledge
the question is really can you
contribute to significant moving of a
needle of producing new knowledge well
the first thing you have to do is to
start
realizing that it's possible to produce
new knowledge at all which is as I say
not something you typically get in
school so you know a typical thing is
you're learning about oh no it's a math
can you make new knowledge in math or is
the math that you learn until you are in
graduate school in math all math that
was done before and you just have to
learn it rather than you have any
capability to make new knowledge in it
well I would claim that it's actually
rather easy you know what what typically
happens is any particular area has been
well explored in the places where it's
been explored kind of goes without
saying but the question is how far off
the track do you have to go before you
get to things that haven't been explored
and is the reason that they haven't been
explored that they're really hard to
explore or is the reason just that
nobody ever looked at that well very
often what you find is the reason nobody
ever looked at that is because in a
sense paradoxically nobody ever looked
at that in in in the following sense
that people develop this idea this is
what one looks at in this particular
area so if there's this thing over here
oh nobody looks at that so one shouldn't
look at that you know it's funny I was
just been working on a thing in
connection with our physics project
that's some a bunch of essentially math
to do with these things we call multi
way systems and multi way systems
operating on numbers and so on and I'm
like why is nobody ever looked at this
before it's I don't think anybody's
looked at it before it's possible they
have I don't think so I think I know the
literature well enough it's it's pretty
Elementary it's not like it it requires
you know okay it's it's got some things
which can make use of some slightly more
advanced math um but it's the question
of why nobody's looked at it before some
allergy here though why nobody's looked
at before is some it's just because the
things that would lead you to look at it
didn't exist they were the the things
that caused you to think that might be
interesting didn't exist it's not that
it's fundamentally hard to look at so I
would say in terms of discovering new
things the first step is can you can you
ask questions that are where you can
make progress and you know when I was a
kid I I guess I didn't really get the
message as clearly as I might that you
know the only like physics you can do is
the physics that's an exercise in books
because I kind of like well there's a
question let me see if I can answer that
question the fact that the answer isn't
in any book that I know about and isn't
and maybe there was an advantage back in
those days that the web didn't exist
because for me it was often do I know
the answer to this question no is it in
the book that I'm looking at well no
okay how do I find out the answer of
this question well I could go and you
know bicycles of the university library
or something and go try and find it
or I could go try and figure it out
myself it might be a lot faster to try
and figure it out myself and so that's a
but but also you know this this
realization that yes you can figure
things out yourself that aren't haven't
been figured out before is is a really
good one to have now in modern times the
whole computational methodology is one
that is sort of new to our time and so
once you know kind of a certain amount
of the tools of computation there's just
so much that can be figured out where
people haven't have figured it out not
because it's hard but because they never
looked at that because they didn't have
the tools they didn't think about things
that way and so on so I think you know
my number one suggestion is go try and
figure out things and and I would say
that it's it's satisfying when you can
figure them out in a very concrete way
you know you write a program it does
this you get a result you can show it to
people and you know it's better than
sort of having some generalized idea
that you're sort of describing sort of
more philosophically rather than
concretely because that's a lot harder
to to really be sure you know what
you're talking about for yourself and to
communicate to other people so I think
this kind of sort of actually do things
build new stuff think about new
questions you know a general strategy
okay
so for given a field
how do you figure out something new and
interesting about that field my slightly
outrageous general strategies is more or
less this first question is what is the
central problem of the field right like
take a field I don't know
chemistry let's say alright we might say
the central problem of chemistry is to
make a molecule make some form of
molecule it doesn't useful even just to
construct a molecule with any given form
or to make a molecule with any given
property you know you specify property I
want my molecule to do this and that and
to absorb lights and do this and do this
and there's that and then it's like well
okay how do I get you know how do I make
a molecule that does that you can think
of that maybe I don't know if it just
thought of this I'm not sure it's quite
quite right but you can think of that at
least one of the sort of central
problems of chemistry ok so then we
start thinking about well what can we
say about that central problem you know
people have been working on chemistry
for a long time there's tens of millions
of chemical compounds that are no 1 that
are catalogued etc how can we make
progress well that general problem is
really hard but we can start thinking
about well you know if we start thinking
about all the chemical reactions that
exists can we imagine what are all the
possible ways we can might be able to
arrange chemical reactions what would
their outcomes be those kinds of things
we can start thinking about oh if we're
going to build molecules sort of step by
step how would we make sort of molecule
templates that would allow us to do that
I'm not sure these are you know these
are all complicated things but the the
point that I'm making is that given the
central problem of a field there are
often ways into that central problem
that have not been explored and which
are there'll be a set of things that
have been explored those things will
prolong long ago of lost sight of the
central problem and so often if you try
and drill into the central problem
perhaps using new methods new ideas and
so on you may get somewhere you probably
won't solve the central problem but
you'll you'll have made progress and
it's kind of a way to make sure that
what you're doing is ultimately relevant
to the field so anyway that's a sort of
a a an approach I mean I would say that
in general the problem of discover
for example new science is as I would
say first and foremost is a problem of
asking the right questions the the
difficulty of like oh can we figure out
the answer given that we've really got
the right question is much lower than
the than the difficulty of you know can
we really formulate the right question
I'm formulating the right question is
often a matter of sort of understanding
how to think about a particular kind of
problem so for instance some oh I don't
know like like the thing I mentioned
about chemistry you know how to think
about that problem that we think about
molecules and reactions in some kind of
computational form or do we think about
it in terms of whether it's a white
powdered chemical or something um it's
you know the it's sort of a question of
of how we how we build up the framework
to think about things but I would say
that the in terms of the original
question about sort of teenagers doing
new science it's like go find some
problems that are problems that are not
that are just your own idea your own
question you know I wonder about this I
wonder about that if you wonder about it
don't assume that oh the answer is
already known somebody must have figured
that out don't assume that because it
often isn't true I mean I I'm you know
in fields that I'm not necessarily you
know never worked on I often wonder
about the answer to some question I'll
usually file it away as I kind of wonder
about this and then sometime I'll run
into you know the world expert on that
field and then I'll say oh by the way I
was wondering about asking this question
and I would say probably I would say
half of the time they say no that's it
that's a reasonable question nobody
knows the answer and the other half of
the time they'll say oh yeah yeah we
know the answer sometimes they'll say we
just figured it out this year and
sometimes they'll say oh no that that
was know 100 years ago um so it's really
a wide range and you shouldn't assume to
you know that the answer is known
immediately and that's a good good set
up for any questions people want to ask
here and I can try and tell you whether
I
with right weather I know the answer or
not okay question from stahma and how do
I feel about academia versus self-made
people is there a place place for
natural self-taught talent you know I
mean at some level I would consider
myself sort of self-taught except that I
went to you know top schools and so on
and I I let lots of things there most of
the things that I actually that are
central for the things I've done in my
life I didn't learn in school you know I
learnt things like Latin and Greek and
by Lenten a certain amount of math and I
learned I look by I suppose I learned a
bunch of stuff about writing English and
so on in school I didn't learn anything
about you know a lot of kinds of science
that I worked on technology and so on I
didn't never learnt those things in
school I learnt all those things by just
letting myself I probably helped that I
had learnt things in school and I'd
learned to set them out about how to
learn so to speak plus the things that I
learned in school have actually turned
out to be very useful to me I'm pretty
much all of them and some at some time
or another so you know there's sort of a
question of to what extent one is going
to learn things for oneself to what it's
dump one needs you know it's it's useful
to sort of learn the standard things
that are known so a thing to say you
know the idea of I'm just going to
figure out everything for myself I'm not
gonna leverage any existing knowledge
that's a mistake
you know our civilization has come a
long way we've learnt a lot of stuff and
it's a you know if you say I'm just
gonna figure out physics from scratch
and just ignore everything that's known
in physics let me figure out everything
from scratch probably not a good idea
there's a lot that's know and that's
that's really worthwhile the the now
often you know for me for example I have
ended up being involved in sort of
trying to rewrite the foundations of
some fields but I have to say I think
I'd done my homework pretty well in
those fields typically I mean I
typically know what's known
and I have to sometimes say well I'm
gonna ignore part of what's known but I
do know what's known and it's it's not
one of these things which like oh I
don't understand what's know and so I'm
gonna invent it all for myself
it's more like do your homework know
what's known and then decide if you like
it or not and whether you want to change
the foundations or or not so I would say
that that sometimes when people talk
about sort of self-taught they mean you
know don't learn any of the existing
knowledge I think that's a mistake in
terms of you know do you go through the
sort of the the the apparatus of the
standard education system you know
that's a challenge sometimes and it's
particularly a challenge for people who
are really quite creative thinkers
because that's not what the education
system is mostly about the education
system is mostly about kind of this the
structured tract that has certain sort
of that involves you know I mean
sometimes it's like should you go to
this College well will you fit into this
College okay you may fit into this
College but that doesn't necessarily
mean that you know fitting into the
college is not the same thing as saying
you'll have the most brilliant
innovative insights it means you're
fitting into some existing framework and
I think that the so it is sometimes a
challenge for you know if one is is
going to do things in a sort of a very
creative way it's it's a challenge to
sort of navigate through the the the
educational system sometimes and and not
to get to the point where one is so sort
of bored and frustrated by the fact that
oh I'm having to do the same thing I'm
not able to do something innovative and
creative so I think it's important you
know people particularly I would say in
the case through 12 education system
people make themselves so busy these
days I mean it's like you know I think
of myself you know I spend my time
running companies doing science writing
things all that kind of stuff you might
think I would be a busy person you know
yes I have a heavily scheduled life and
so on but somehow it seems like many of
the teenagers I know are vastly busier
than I am and
at least have the have project the image
of being vastly busier than I am um and
you know I think sometimes think that's
a pity because you know it's like
they're doing this this this this this
but it's like okay but you know you
might just you know block off some time
and use it to think and use it to do
some project that you just think is
interesting it does it's not necessarily
a project that leads to this that leads
to that leads to that leads to that um
it's a project that you want to do
because it's interesting and may turn
out if you do the project cuz it's
interesting you discover something
really interesting that term that other
people think it's really cool
it may also turn out that nobody else
cares but you like it yourself and
that's a good thing to and I think that
you know part of this some I would say
you know make sure you leave some time
to do stuff you're actually interested
in not stuff you're doing for the sake
of some particular track that you're on
that will lead to the next track that
your own lead to the next track and so
on I mean I would say that in my life if
I look at a lot of the things I've done
many of the things I've done started as
quotes hobbies I mean back you know I
was a professor at one point and I sort
of had a hobby of doing things in the
technology industry and then pretty soon
I was a technology industry CEO and I
kind of had a hobby of doing science and
pretty soon I was doing that in a in a
sort of for real so to speak
I've had it is a you know even even
doing things like writing I've sort of
done as a hobby and and then it ends up
but you know I published books and
things you know for me doing it kind of
as a hobby frees me to do it on my terms
and it often then turns into something
very serious so to speak and I think
that's a thing that's a pretty good
dynamic for everybody it's like okay
there's a track you're on where you can
see the next step of the next step the
next step but just to something that's
that's fun and do it well and it may
turn out it usually will turn out that
um and sometimes it's it you know you do
the thing you do it well and then you
say well does the world care about this
thing well maybe it's not obvious the
world cares about this thing maybe you
have to be a little bit innovative to
find out how to sort of
to present the thing to the right part
of the world to make sure that it cares
about it I mean I I'm kind of reminded
of I know people who are poets for
example and it's like you know and they
they were like how do I get a job doing
you know doing poetry and then Twitter
came along and they realized that the
skills that they knew from writing
poetry were really good if you want to
be a you know a commercial Twitterer so
to speak that was a really useful skill
for that
all right lots of questions
boy let's see um so many questions here
see
um
[Music]
okay a few few questions here I'll try
to address um the question from this is
Prateek do you think language is
evolutionarily inevitable evitable
feature of consciousness and if you find
sentient life fully final language that
the consciousness communicates in um as
a car or a given a language can you find
a consciousness behind it I'm not sure
I'm gonna be able to really do this
question justice um I think this sort of
requires I mean we're talking about a
little bit earlier is the question of
the relationship between language and
thinking so to speak it's a it's a
long-running philosophical discussion I
think that the I mean the main feature
of language as we know it today is it as
a way of communicating abstract ideas
abstracted from their specifics and is
that related to the existence of minds
and so on it's certainly something not
far away um do we have the the
imagination to see what other forms of
abstract communication could exist
between Minds I don't think that we do
and whether language is the only one is
not clear whether symbolic language is
the only one is not clear it's not to me
that is a sort of a way of communicating
abstracted thoughts what is an
abstracted thought I that's a kind of a
high level abstraction the abstraction
of abstraction maybe that's not
appropriate for this for this group okay
there's a question here about some come
out from Thomas saying as a physics
teacher what's my opinion about physics
teaching today I am I am too far away
from the details of what's being done to
have a very informed opinion I would say
I may have a few comments though one of
the challenges sometimes in teaching is
to know you know what concepts are
willy-willy within range and what
concepts are too hard and sometimes the
what's within range and what's too hard
is somehow deduced from history people
say if it took humans hundreds of years
to figure that out it must be too hard
to teach to kids that's not always the
case
it
true that many fields build themselves
up sequentially like for example in
mathematics a certain amount of the
development from arithmetic to algebra
to calculus and so on that recapitulates
history but there are other things that
don't like decimals were invented very
late in history things like binary
numbers were invented but not really
taken seriously until very recently
there are and and the idea of
computation and programmability is a
very recent idea it's an idea from after
the 1930s it's an idea that could have
been had hundreds of years earlier but
wasn't but that idea is actually not a
hard idea to understand and it would be
a mistake to say in order to people did
this actually in the early days of sort
of computer science some people said if
you want to understand how to write a
computer program first you have to
understand mathematical logic and you
have to understand the idea of you know
beta reduction and lambda calculus or
something before you can ever use a
variable in a in a function so to speak
um the but turns out that's not
necessary so they're these places where
the historical development of a subject
does not map into what can readily be
taught you know there were things which
was sort of not necessarily glitches of
history there were things where it
seemed like a tower of abstraction was
needed that that in fact is not now part
of the reason that happens is because
our ambient experience of the world
changes so for example in modern times
we ambiently understand a lot about
computers because computers are
everywhere if one had gone back and said
we're gonna teach physics using
computation as a core component we're
going to teach that a hundred years ago
it's like forget it that's not a it's
not a real thing because computation as
it's now understood just didn't exist
that so you know first thing to say is
there are things that one can teach in
physics I don't know what favorite
example is particle physics there are
aspects of particle physics that are
really elementary to teach you know
protons have three quarks in the more or
less you know there are W bosons that
carriers the weak weak force so all
these kinds of things these can be
taught at almost the same level as a
sort of phenomenological level that
doesn't require you
understand the mathematics of fiber
bundles and local gauging variants and
so on they can be taught as something's
just sort of interesting to know about
the world that's that's one thing to say
another thing I would say about about
physics today is the ability to have
sort of data taken by devices and go
directly onto your computer you know use
Wolfram language use notebooks and
things you know create an analysis of
that data you too can discover all kinds
of physical laws either from data that
you can directly take yourself or the
data from data that you can readily get
from the world you can sort of
rediscover Kepler's laws if you're doing
things with you know with planets so you
can rediscover you know parabolic motion
from videos things like that and it's
rather easy to do that at this point and
and that's something I think might be
interesting um in terms of sort of
traditional okay so so here's a good
exercise now that we think we understand
sort of what quantum mechanics where
quantum mechanics comes from can we
teach it better the answer is I think
most definitely yes have we have we
completely figured out how to do that
not quite getting closer I think we will
have a much cleaner way to describe
quantum mechanics you know can we
describe things like general utility in
a clean way yes the answer is yes we we
have nice clean ways to do that now you
know do I recommend that every physics
course teaches about some sort of the
the continuum limit of hypergraph
rewriting probably not yet although you
know there will come a time when it's
worthwhile you know what some you know
people talk about what's matter made of
well you certainly say it's made of
atoms what space made of hopefully
before too many years have gone by you
know the atoms of space will be a thing
that one can reasonably talk about as as
something in learning physics
um
gosh so many things
you
let's see if there's a question so many
questions here you guys are just asking
so many interesting things um okay
there's a question here about what's my
take on autonomous cars and how long
until they become feasible but Animas
cars are difficult more difficult than
you might imagine I mean there are
situations in which they're fairly easy
you're driving down a freeway the thing
is well mapped there are no obstructions
it's just a question of following the
lane and not running into the car in
front of you
that's a solvable problem the full
problem of a city street with everything
that's going on and all these some kinds
of kinds of things that happen that's a
very hard problem and it's not clear
there are you know they're even fairly
fundamental questions like you know
you're merging into a lane of traffic
you are looking as a human you look at
the other human in the car next to you
say are they gonna let me in are they
knocking Lutton yen how do you figure
that out
are you can you in fact merge into
another lane of traffic without taking a
risk do you have to assert yourself and
just start moving and know that the
other humans will pull back um it's you
know in a few now as soon as you start
having many cars being autonomous and
cars autonomous cars being able to
communicate with autonomous cars again
that becomes an easier problem so so if
for example every car on the road was
autonomous I suspect that's a problem
that can be solved I think the problem
of sort of well defined lanes
well-defined environments where you can
make do autonomous driving that I think
is a very solvable problem and has been
to some extent solved already
the problem of kind of the the
free-range sort of drive anywhere deal
with all the kinds of situations that
can happen this seems to me to be a very
hard problem and people talk about you
in level 1 level 2 level 3 autonomy and
so on and sometimes it's kind of a bit
of a bit of a put-up job because you
know people have this particular area
around mountain view or whatever
very very carefully mapped out and it's
like you know every piece of
and then it becomes a bit easier and you
also know oh gosh there wasn't you know
that thing wasn't there in that
intersection yesterday you know let me
be more careful here so to speak so
there are the sort of little slights of
hand in a sense that that happened there
I mean there are also very practical
things like lidar laser radar so to
speak those things that you see those
big there's big sort of round things you
see on the top of self-driving cars
those have spinning laser things in them
that are mapping out the
three-dimensional environment around the
car traditionally those things have been
rather expensive and complicated there
will be much cheaper ones of those and
that will surely help in being able to
give a a beyond human view of what's
around a car fully in three dimensions
and so on and that helps in being able
to make decisions but you know I think a
good test case is what are the most
exotic things that happen when one's
driving and come on figure out what to
do and you know I sometimes hear from
people who work on farmer's cars and I I
was asking the question at one point if
you're doing Quality Assurance for an
autonomous cars that is can you you know
the Quality Assurance involves testing
what happens if this happened what
happens if that happens what happens if
it's in snow what happens if this
whatever so what's the most exotic thing
you've seen and I think one person told
me that - one of the things they saw was
a situation where the Thomas car comes
up to place in the road where there's a
woman on one of those kind of right
around wheelchair like things but but
not quite a wheelchair and there were
some ducks in the middle of the road and
the woman was circling around the ducks
to protect them from oncoming traffic
and it's like what is that
says the autonomous car you know what is
going on here there are ducks there's a
person there's a person that's circling
around in the middle of the road what's
going on and you know that's a hard
thing how do you how do you give their
own autonomous car information of what
to do in that situation it's not um you
know it has to have that some level oh
just has to say oh I give
you know beep-beep-beep have the human
take over or something so I you know I
suspect it's a hard problem
I think it's some the as I say it's it's
a problem that has some sort of societal
pieces like if you if you carve off sort
of special lanes for self-driving cars
then that's a lot easier and if you say
this whole environment is pure
self-driving then that's easier and you
know people try to do things like they
say let's have a self-driving setup
where the thing is only making
right-hand turns or it's only turning in
this way and you know you might have to
go a little bit further on the roads but
it's going to be easier because it's
completely it doesn't have to deal with
any weird complicated left turn into
oncoming traffic and and things like
that situation and that's another kind
of approach to doing it but I think it's
a I think it's a fairly difficult
problem to solve in general and like
like a lot of engineering problems I'm
solving a partial version of the problem
that is still very very useful to people
is is a good solution and it's still
very useful if you can you know drive
autonomously on a highway on a freeway
you know if you can drive a truck
autonomously on a freeway and things a
very very useful thing even if you
haven't solved the full problem for
arbitrary driving let's see it's a
question from Nick here books for
curious teens wanting to learn about
science I have to recommend my own new
kind of science book and particularly
the notes in the back of that book which
I was I on reencountering notes that I
wrote there which I think are it's like
I look at a page on Wikipedia and I look
at the note that I wrote about the thing
it's like well maybe it's just because I
wrote the note it's clearer clearer to
me but it's like I think this is a much
clearer description of what's going on
so I would recommend you can find that
book online that's one thing I would
recommend it's uh gosh
you know I would recommend I mean you
know the elementary textbooks or the the
college 101 textbooks of many fields
have often been
well laid-out they're very you know
they're very well presented and a lot of
effort has been put into them and you
know sometimes they may be a little dry
but nevertheless you know flipping
through their pages and looking at the
box on this page the thing on that page
it's it's a good idea you can ignore all
of the structured exercises and so on if
you just want to get an idea of what's
going on
but I think it's a it's a it's a good
way you know a lot of effort has been
putting put into making those kinds of
things a sort of bird's eye view of
their field and I guess I would
recommend that as a general approach um
let's see ah somebody's commenting that
the the self-driving car QA example was
AI meets untitled goose yeah that's some
um ok there's a question here ok there's
a question here from student doctor how
do you go about building a team around
you to solve the problems you want to
work on oh boy that's a challenging
question um you know I think what's a
good answer to that that's it all
generalizable I mean I've been very
fortunate that over the years because we
have a company that makes products that
are well known well used by lots of
people lots of interesting folk sort of
come into our orbit somehow they use our
products they interact with us in some
way or another we get to know them and
then when there's a project coming along
it's like gosh who do we know who might
be really interested and really good at
this project so I would say that the
actually I yes let me let me let me say
it this way I would say for me the
number one thing is having a good
network myself of of people I know who
know about lots of different kinds of
things and even when the particular
thing they know about isn't something
that I have a specific reason to care
about right then it's just like you know
keep in touch because you know some
years some decade there may be something
you know if you find the person
interesting and you find what they do
interesting even if it's not
specifically connected to what you're
doing right now it's like maybe it will
be in ten years um I think that's been
an important thing for me I mean I would
say that it's been a source of both both
personal I would say personally good
thing and a good thing sort of in terms
of the development of things I've done
in practical world that you know I just
have a very big network of people that I
know and I keep keep in touch with
people I mean I'm in touch with a decent
fraction of the people I knew and well
certainly on entry school and even to
some extent kender garden which is a
long depressingly long time go for me
now but and I think these days by easier
to stay in touch because people are like
on social media and things like this but
it's like stay in touch and you you find
out you know one of the terrible things
is you know I I recently went to an
elementary school reunion and source of
people I hadn't seen in 50 years and I
realized that you know you start talking
to them and it feels like you know you
just start the conversation where you
left off fifty years ago and you you
know you've had a lot of experience in
between but you're still the same people
and it still sort of works the same way
so I would I would say that part of it
is is just um sort of having a network
of people you know then you know you can
always go you know their places to sort
of find people and so on then there's a
question when you build a team for
something what you know how do you make
the team really do stuff and I would say
they if you're leading a team and
somebody has to lead it it you know I I
have almost never seen a a serious
innovative project happen without
leadership and so what is the role of
the leader the number one role of the
leader is to define the vision and to
convince people that what you're
proposing to do is actually possible I
mean I think that you know a lot of what
I've spent my time doing is convincing
teams of people that what we're trying
to do is not impossible
and then the typical pattern is this
I'll say I have this idea we're gonna
build wolf now for example because they
owe it's impossible there's too much of
this it's too hard to understand natural
language it's too etc etc so then you
know I'll let people work on it a bit
and then say ok they say oh it's just
not possible
ok why isn't it possible tell me what's
not possible ok we can't solve this
problem we can't solve that problem say
ok let's work on this problem let me try
and help you solve that problem ok bash
on it for a while and they say oh yeah
yeah I guess we can solve that problem
that's cool and now we can go on and
take the next step so a lot of the
leadership of projects has to do with in
my experience has to do with defining
what the goals are then sort of sort of
convincing people that those things are
possible and it's no good to just say
it's possible go solve the problem you
got to be involved in solving the
problem yourself as well I think the
other point is sometimes what you have
defined to do simply as impossible and
usually what's the case of what I found
it essentially always in projects I've
done is even if the thing you at first
defined is sort of hitting a hard place
where you just just can't do it
you can redefine the objectives a little
bit to still achieve a large part of
what you want to do or maybe even a
better objective than you originally had
and that project is possible and so
that's an another piece to the picture
of sort of how do you you know how do
you lead such a team now you know what
can happen is when you try and assemble
teams of people the you know one of the
challenges is why are people doing this
you know everybody does stuff for some
internal reason and your role as a
leader of the team is to define why it's
exciting to do something why it's worth
doing something why people should value
doing that thing and you know how to
think about the thing so that it is
something that people will the people
who are doing it will value doing I
think that's an important thing now
sometimes you know you try and assemble
a team and there's somebody who really
wants to do something different well
they probably won't fit in your team and
if you try and make them fit it'll be
super frustrating and they'll
you know and and and and they'll sort of
distort the project you know I was
talking to some kids I I interact with
recently and was talking to them about
leaving projects and about the question
of if you're doing like a joint project
with other kids in school and the other
kids just don't won't do what you want
what do you do and you know I was saying
that I think everybody has a different
personality for managing people and
things not everybody is necessarily so
cut out for telling other people what to
do
um it's but turns out more people than
you might think can do that even people
who you might think I was very sort of
mousy and retiring people you might
think of is very sort of loud and
outgoing you know there many different
personalities that can can lead people
and and they're different ways to lead
people I mean in my particular my
particular approach is more about sort
of lead by defining objectives and
creating enthusiasm so to speak other
people have a more structured way of
leading and where they where they help
people to understand this is the exact
next step you should take this is the
next step is the next step they provide
a very structured setup which many
people find a much easier thing to sort
of pursue I mean they're people another
thing to say is when you build a team
you the leader of the team have to there
will be certain people that can work
with you and there certainly will who
can't work with you and it's not that
the people are bad people are good
people it's just do they fit with you or
not so for me there are types of people
who can work well with me and I can work
well with them and there are types of
people where I Drive them crazy they
drive me crazy you know I know that
they're not people where where there's a
good fit there and not that they're not
you know I can say sometimes I'll say to
somebody look you know you will be a
great fit working for a large company
that has you know hundreds of thousands
of employees you're not going to be you
know a good fit working for a company
that has 800 employees um it's you know
it's a different different kinds of
things that that go on there's different
level of structure that exists there and
it's the same with any project whether
it's you know project
in school with kids or whether it's a
project you're trying to do that's
building some piece of technology to the
world there'll be people who are sort of
a fit for the environment that you have
in the leadership you can provide in
there people who are not and you know
learning how to recognize that is very
useful I mean I think that you know in
my own experience the you know if I if
I'm trying to sort of interact with
somebody interview them figure out are
they gonna be a good fit for my team my
project whatever you know what I like to
be able to do is is say after I've
talked to the person I think I know this
person well enough now that if I imagine
for myself a question what would the
person do if such and such a situation
arose that I think I can answer that
question if I can't answer the question
I said I just have no idea I couldn't
figure that out then typically it's kind
of not promising to for me to work with
that person just in terms of the way
that that I tend to do things but anyway
I can
discussing management is probably a
different different topic um the um
let's see ah okay someone is asking here
about some business oh there's all kinds
of questions here what's the future of
fiat currency questions about business
all right let me take the one about
business and then I want the one about
two fiat currency so there's a question
here from I see you know I've seen this
handle before and I gotta figure out how
to pronounce it I'll call it I see um
question is about business knowledge and
you know okay so so I've started
basically two companies in my life first
run when I was about 21 years old the
second one was about 26 years old I'm
still running the one I started when I
was 26 years old I mean it's actually
multiple companies but conceptually it's
it's some kind of 1:1 initiative or from
research um and um so you know I would
say that um there again there are
different ways to have a business and to
run a business and they're very
different personalities you know it's
it's funny when if you meet up with a
gathering of people who run businesses
entrepreneurs people well those are two
different things people there are people
who start businesses and there are
people who run businesses but may not
have started businesses different
different collections of people um but
particularly if you look at the people
who start businesses and run them it's a
very diverse collection of people from
the very people oriented people to the
very nerdy people to the very
intellectual people to the very kind of
salesy people to the people where it's
like where they're very eloquent and
they can give a big speech to the people
who can barely string words together
just a very wide range of people very
wide range of backgrounds very wide
range of personalities and they all have
the thing in common that they've started
built successful companies you know so
there are different ways into doing it
and there are different goals that
people have even for some people like
for me the company is sort of all about
the products we build for other people
it's all about making money for example
or it's all about kind of the or its oh
it's sort of specifically about the set
of people you're working with I I'd like
very much and said the people I work
with and for me that's important but in
a sense the the the number one thing for
me is sort of the intellectual
development of products and so on
um the I think that you know the first
thing to think about in terms of
companies is you know make a company
that you care about so to speak you know
people sometimes have this idea that
oh I'll make a company cuz it'll be
successful even though I don't really
care about the thing it makes I really
care about what it's doing I mean you
know there are people who have companies
it's kind of funny for me sometimes I'll
meet somebody their CEO of some company
and the company makes some you know very
technical thing I'll ask about it and
it's completely clear the person does
not care about the technical thing what
the person cares about is the mechanism
for selling the technical thing which
itself is very interesting no question
about it me you can be interesting that
it's not my primary interest but but
that's a thing in itself you know it's
something where it's like it's not so
much about the product it's about you
know the way we deliver the product it's
about the service that we provide to
customers etc etcetera etcetera that's a
perfectly valid thing to be interested
in but it's different from necessarily
being interested in the product on its
own so you know that's that's one thing
I would say that anybody who says I've
got a scheme I've got some kind of I've
got this magic idea that's going to you
know make money solve the problems of
the world schemes never work out it's
you know maybe I have a an overly
puritanical view of this but I you know
and what I've seen it's it's hard work
to build something real and and it's
never there are almost never kind of
little free rides where we're you know
oh it's just it's just with this one
clever idea and then everything sort of
falls into place it's hard work and by
the way when people sort of sign up for
starting companies and things it's a you
know it's not something you do as as
kind of a oh I'm gonna do this one hour
a week type thing um now you know having
said that there's sort of a tendency I
think it's a little bit dying off these
days but there was a period of time when
it's like everybody should be a tech
entrepreneur you know it's like and
there were classes about you know how to
make your Minimum Viable Product how to
give your elevator pitch you know all
these terms are for me it's kind of
amusing because I've been in the tech
industry long enough that I I remember
when all those concepts were introduced
of sort of the minimal viable products
and so on and now you know sometimes
I've been visiting in different places
around the world and I'll I'll visit
some high school or something and people
will be talking about you know on the
whiteboard they'll have all this stuff
where high school kids about you know
Minimum Viable Product
elevator pitch you know whatever it's
kind of interesting that that sort of
been a consumer eyes idea for sort of
this this idea of entrepreneurism for
everybody now you know it is
entrepreneurism is an interesting thing
to learn about it's an interesting way
of viewing the world but it is not for
everybody
um and you know I think that it is some
and it isn't the right way to think
about every project that gets done I
mean it's like people over time invent
all of these magic this is the way to
think about projects so for example um
oh I don't know like in in in software
developments there are these things like
everything has to be object-oriented
everything has to be done with agile
everything has to be done with whatever
and sometimes these things have an
almost you know a kind of a strange
almost cult-like character of like
everybody has to have a stand-up meeting
it's very important people be standing
for this amount of time you know now you
know these things work for some people
and don't work for other people it's
some you know I along these lines of
sort of the standardized way to do
things there was a scheme it was big in
the Soviet Union actually at one point
called triz I don't know what that
stands for it's probably in Russian um
but anyway it was a it was a a meta it
was a scheme for inventing things okay
so it was a very I mean I think in
Soviet Union was very big on kind of
these very structured you know we will
make this five year plan we will do this
everything is very planned everything's
very structured so the question is how
do you do innovation how do you do
structured innovation okay so there's a
scheme for doing structure generation
and it's a procedure for innovating and
you know the procedure works by
basically saying you imagine if you look
at patents that describe inventions and
you say there's a patent that means this
is a pattern that means that and then
there's you know there's one patent that
does this on I don't know optics and
there's another pattern that does this
on electrical systems so there must be
something in between that is sort of
does that on the other the other kind of
system or whatever so sort of a an you
know like all these things it it has the
feature of that yeah and it has some
good ideas but it is not the whole
story for this is the grand machine
that's going to lead to elimination and
Anor is entrepreneurism etc etc etc but
but you know so you know things about
business I mean I think that if you're
making products not every business is
about making products but um I mean I
said first thing is do a business that
you enjoy the idea of doing a business
that you don't enjoy particularly
starting one is kind of crazy
um and although there will be pieces
that are really hard work and you may
not locally enjoy them um I think that
the another thing that I've noticed
about business is you know engaged of
thinking apparatus on all issues and you
know don't just assume again there are
different ways to run companies okay so
I should say that so some people when
they run a company they say ok I'm a CEO
and I'm just gonna get in experts who
know about this and this and this and
this and this and I'm just gonna be the
conductor of the orchestra so to speak
and each you know I'll get the the
public relations person I'll get the the
the DevOps person I'll get this person
and get with that person I'll get the
developer I'll get all these kinds of
things and I put them all together and
then something wonderful will happen but
I don't understand any of those areas um
and for me that's completely different
from the way I've I've always done
things I find that very hard to
understand how people could do that how
they can sort of be the conductor
without understanding the pieces for me
you know my theory of companies tends to
be on day one the CEO does everything
and gradually as you understand more and
more about how things work you can hire
people who do things at least as well if
not better than you do those particular
things and that has the you know it has
the feature that for my company for most
areas I can kind of dive in and actually
do the work on the ground pretty much
every area where I can't we probably
have not historically done as well as
other areas and so for me at least it's
sort of understanding things through and
through is really important to being
able to to make business you know I this
is supposed to be for mostly for kids so
I'm gonna I'm gonna stop yakking about
business here I can talk about business
some other time there's there's lots to
say about about sort of how to think
about some
ah at least my view of how to think
about business how to think about
innovation in business and so on
let's see
okay oh there was a question here
future of fiat currency so first I
should explain what that means
so fiat currency is the stuff we we all
use as money dollars euros yen whatever
there's sort of this new and different
idea about making currencies which is
digital currencies Bitcoin was the first
example from 2009 and there are there
are now a whole plethora of other
examples so so what's the difference
between fiat currency so what is Bitcoin
Bitcoin is purely electronic purely
digital money where you can say I have
some number of Bitcoin I can pay you in
Bitcoin for something and you can pay me
and there's this whole so the ecosystem
of of purely purely digital money and
there's a whole mechanism which I could
describe a little bit of about how
so-called cryptocurrencies work and how
and how you sort of secure you know one
of the one of the ways that
cryptocurrencies work is at some level
there is a ledger there's a there's a
record of who owns exactly how much
Bitcoin now you don't know who the
actual individual people are you just
know some address but tons so you don't
know who owns the money but you know
address number such-and-such owns this
amount of Bitcoin and it's it's
completely known for the whole history
of Bitcoin every transaction is logged
in fact in Wolfram language you can just
go and say you know blockchain
transaction data of some transaction ID
for the Bitcoin blockchain you can pull
up every transaction that ever happened
on the Bitcoin blockchain and so that's
kind of the way that you know that
somebody has certain assets is because
there's a ledger that just says this
person has these assets it's a little
bit like the way that you know if you
say who owns that house there's
ultimately a a title registry where
somewhere there's conceptually at least
a piece of paper that says this is the
person that owns that house okay so in
in the case of of fiat currency the
oh and there's sort of a question of
okay so then a big question is why is
Bitcoin valuable why does somebody say I
can buy a cup of coffee for this number
of Satoshi which is a tiny unit of a
Bitcoin umm it's some you know why can I
wires why is my cup of coffee worth I
don't know the current conversion rate
tensor tashi or something umm it's some
you know what what is the thing that is
the producer of value for Bitcoin after
all you know we know who owns it but why
is any of this stuff worth anything and
that's a sort of key question instead of
the theory of money is why is it worth
anything and fundamentally the answer is
it's worth something because people
think it's worth something I mean by the
time people think that if they exchange
their cup of coffee if they sell you a
cup of coffee for tensed atashi and they
have that 10 Satoshi and they think oh
that tense was always worth something
because they can go to somebody else and
they can buy a muffin for the 10 Satoshi
or something then then you know then
that's because everybody believes it's
worth something so so sort of a question
of how does that really work
how does value get generated for money
and for for sort of people have been you
know that's been a confusing thing
through history so back in the day you
know the reason money was worth
something was because the physical coins
were worth something they were made of
gold or silver and why was gold or
silver with something well they were
scarce and people and when things are
scarce people are prepared to pay people
that they they represent something that
people that has sort of value to people
and because it's a scarce thing it sort
of maintains that value so so back in
the day the good the coins themselves
were made of gold and silver and you
could actually say this coin I can give
you this coin and return for a pig and
that coin is a lump of gold and this
lump of gold is definitely worth
something because because everybody
knows that gold is worth something it's
gas and I can go in and buy you know
some food for my for my other pigs or
something what would
with that money okay so then there was a
as sort of things developed in history
really in the last hundred years
actually the this this idea of a sort of
a gold standard for you know this okay
so okay then the next big thing was you
know who issues the money how does that
work well government's just see the
money they provide to roll back a little
bit simplest way to run an economy is
just barter for things you say I'll
exchange a pig for a bunch of barley and
you'll get then I'll exchange this you
know fixing your roof for a for a
hamster or you know whatever it is it's
all just barter and there doesn't have
to be any sort of abstract medium it's a
little bit like we're talking about
symbolic language and things money is
the kind of abstract medium of value
that is where you say you know you don't
have to have you don't have to exchange
a you know the barley for a pig you can
exchange money abstract money for the
pig okay so why does that make sense
well it has to be the case that this
abstract money should be something that
um that everybody recognizes has value
of a certain certain level of value now
it is not self-evident that money that
there's a that you can have a single
thing called money so to speak it could
be the case that economies would not
have something that's a sort of a medium
that can be exchanged for everything it
could be the case that you know you buy
food with one kind of thing there's one
sort of token that represents you know
that's forgetting things with food and
there's a completely different token
that's for buying I don't know access to
movies or something and in a sense
whenever people are trying to you know
get you to get you know some kind of
special card that's you know sells you
credits for some for some particular
goods or whatever or some particular
company that's sort of breaking away
from the idea of money as a universal
medium of value but what has turned out
to be the case is that for economies
that there is a meaningful you
for medium of value that we can think of
as being this thing we call money so
then the question is what you know how
does that work how does money how does
it maintain its value what happens you
know so so there was a time when money
was always exchangeable for gold
well you said well gold has value and we
kind of know how much value it has
because kind of roughly there's a
certain amount of gold in the world
there's a certain number of people that
so defines the value because of the
amount of gold and the number of people
and so everybody can have only this
amount and so on and so on and so on
that sort of is a way of maintaining a
constancy of value but you know after a
while it became impractical to do that
and for example when paper money came
into existence people realized well
actually the exchange ability for this
tangible gold doesn't make any sense
it's just a piece of paper and we can
use that piece of paper to say it's
promising somebody so so for example I'm
trying to remember what the American
dollars say I know that the British
pounds the the you know there was a time
when a pound note was exchangeable for a
pound of maybe silver I'm not sure where
you could go into the you know the
government central bank and you could
say his might his my pound note now hand
me my my pound of whatever it was silver
or something but it rapidly became clue
I wasn't a practical way to do things
and so instead there was this moment
when when it changed at least on British
currency and it said you know it said on
the on the on the pound notes it said
you know I promised to pay the bearer on
demand the sum of one pound
signed you know the treasurer of the
country what that whatever the heck that
means you know I promise to pay the sum
of one pound well it's not really saying
one pound of what it's kind of a a
typical kind of way of sort of defining
something without defining something
well anyway so then there's the sort of
notion of a value that is something that
is let's see I'm about to back into kind
of a whole economics lesson here but but
there's sort of this question of what
maintains the value of
a of a currency or gosh this is kind of
complicated I I think the I mean then
they're issues like for example
phenomena like inflation like the idea
that you know if I save up my dollars my
hundred dollars today might buy me a
certain number of candy bars but in 10
years that hundred dollars will buy me
less candy bars because there's been
inflation and the most common phenomenon
that seems to happen throughout history
with a few exceptions is that there is
inflation that is that the the price of
things the the list price of things the
number of dollars written on sort of
this is how much the candy bar costs
gradually increases sometimes hard to
track that because you say how much of
price is increased over time well we're
not buying the same things that we
bought a hundred years ago so you have
to kind of have this basket this bucket
of things that constitute sort of a
standard set of things one buys and you
have to sort of translate that over time
times to think of the Consumer Price
Index CPI which is an attempt to sort of
track that kind of information but Tim
so there's this phenomenon of inflation
which is a phenomenon that seems to
happen in currencies and you know
exactly why it happens it's still
somewhat subject to debate I mean you
know a lot of explanations that I hear
wind up with well prices go up well yes
that's what inflation is why does it
happen and to what extent can it can be
controlled and let's not get into the
whole details of of how banks lend money
and how central bank's relate to that
and her interest rates work and so on
I'd be happy to to explain what I at
least know about those things at some
point but Tim okay so but but
fundamentally the the maintenance of
value for money is is because people
think it's valuable and they think that
you know X number of dollars is going to
be something that they can exchange for
goods that they want okay now in in part
the reason they think that is because
there's sort of a stabilizing element
which is a government is suing that
money the government is saying they're
going to put
on that money they're not going to like
let people print dollars you know at
random they're not just going to let
somebody in there in their garage print
dollars and flood the market with more
dollars and so the value of a particular
dollar goes down and so on the the I
think come um it's okay so you know so
that's kind of the you know currencies
as they exist the fiat currencies are
all sort of associated with governments
that sort of guarantee value with the
central banks of those governments that
are just interest rates to maintain
things with the fact that ultimately you
know the country is backed by the force
of sort of people who say oh your money
is worth nothing they can go and you
know roll out the tanks and complain so
to speak okay so that's how sort of at
least very skating along the surface of
how sort of ordinary sort of fiat
currencies will go say something like
Bitcoin why is Bitcoin worth anything
who guarantees the value of Bitcoin well
it's not clear the and there in fact
wild fluctuations I mean talk about
inflation that's not really been seen in
the digital currencies
what's instead happened is these wild
you know going up going down sort of
pricing of these kinds of things much
more like prices of stocks than of
typical currencies now you know is there
a way to stabilize a little currency
that's a very interesting question
what do you need to be able to do that
do you need a central bank that's
deciding oh let's make more Bitcoin
let's make less Bitcoin and so on the
way Bitcoin worked it's actually kind of
a bizarre thing because it actually was
based on an idea I think of mine I mean
we don't know who the inventor of
Bitcoin was but I rather think that a
key idea of Bitcoin actually came from
some science work that I did in the
1980s on this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility so what how
does Bitcoin sort of
create value how does it decide you know
when when somebody mines gold from the
ground somebody gets that gold somebody
and certain other people don't how do
you decide who gets you know who gets
the gold you have to go to effort to get
the gold well in Bitcoin you do this
thing called mining or a so called
proof-of-work well what you're doing is
to essentially solve math problems which
are computationally irreducible so
they're they're solving this problem
it's a sort of cryptographic math
problem and the problem is arranged to
be of a certain difficulty and it's like
you have to kind of have to solve this
problem in order to mine a Bitcoin in
order to basically be the original
person who mines the goal out of the
ground to start the chain of sort of
creating values so to speak and it's
sort of bizarre for me because you know
this idea of computational
irreducibility which start as a very
abstract idea pretty soon you're
discovering they're these giant banks of
computers that are mining Bitcoin and
are using huge amounts of electricity to
do so because they're grinding through
this phenomenon of computational
reducibility
as a way of generating value I actually
don't think it's the right way to do it
I think it was sort of a patch for how
to do it at that time and in the history
of ideas about computation but still
that's the way it's done but ok so then
then there's this you have a Bitcoin and
why is it worth what it's worth well
it's not really backed by any kind of
economic activity see the thing is when
you deal with dollars or something like
that there's trillions of dollars of
actual economic activity of people
actually buying and selling pigs and
barley and and chocolate and all kinds
of other things and and software and so
on and there's a lot of economic
activity and that economic activity is
happening in dollars it makes a big
difference in the world like for example
I think at some time in history it was
decided that oil prices will be quoted
in dollars a big deal that they're
quoted in dollars and not in some other
currency because that means that dollars
become the medium of exchange for for
example oil and so there's a and there's
real economic activity around dollars so
in the case of Bitcoin it could be the
case that there was real economic
activity around people buying and
selling cups of coffee with Bitcoin but
there isn't
and so instead what happened is that
most of these digital currencies most of
the money that's going into and out of
them is speculation it's people saying
I'm gonna put money into Bitcoin on the
on the hope that the value of Bitcoin
relative relative to dollars for example
is going to go up and I'm gonna make
money from it and then somebody else
will sort of take the other side of that
and say no I think it's gonna go down
I'm going to sell my Bitcoin and so on
and so it's that kind of process of
making a speculative market that has
been the primary activity that's
happened around crypto currencies to
this point and I don't think it's
ultimately a very supportable thing
because I think that that term if there
was real economic activity around crypto
currencies you have something just like
dollars and so on where where you have
them some sort of stability that comes
from a sort of underlying iceberg of
activity um where instead of just pure
speculation now I personally think that
computational contracts the ability of
computers to sort of make agreements
with each other and for us to represent
what we would otherwise write in real
legalese in computational language and
have those things be be things that are
executed between computers I think that
will ultimately be the thing that makes
crypto currency makes sense because that
will be something where there's real
economic activity that's happening
purely in the computational domain and
where it makes sense to have some medium
of value that is itself purely
computational now you know people also
say so occasionally various countries
whose own currencies have been in in
trouble have considered adopting crypto
currencies purely digital currencies as
alternatives their own currency I think
it happened in Argentina
I think people talked about it for
Venezuela countries where there's been
trouble with their own currency I I
think if that actually happened it would
for any particular digital currency for
example for an existing one like Bitcoin
it would dramatically change the
dynamics and it would sort of become
Argentinian Bitcoin so to speak or
something like that it would not stay
the way it is right now people hope ok I
say one last thing about this but people
hope that ok interesting story the the
question is do you need humans and like
central banks and
sort of human media for sort of
maintaining economic stability to exist
or is it enough to just have algorithms
maintaining a cryptocurrency um the a
good example of this with the etherion
cryptocurrency there was a thing a few
years ago called the Dow the digital
autonomous organization I think that's
right right terminology for it anyway it
was a it was essentially a an investment
vehicle of venture capital thing that
was going to be done using aetherium and
it's big sort of slogan was it has no
human oversight
it's just determined by code everything
that happens is determined by code okay
so a lot of money was put into this
thing and somebody walked off with 50
million dollars but they did it by just
running code and the code that they ran
was code that was completely valid code
within the framework that had been built
for this digital autonomous thing and
and so the question was did they do
anything wrong well they're the intent
of this of putting the money into this
thing was that it be used for lots of
little projects it wasn't the intent
that somebody would just sort of walk
off with the money
um but what they did was completely
consistent with the system of quotes
laws that have been created around this
thing it was just everything was
supposed to work with code and they were
running a piece of code and so it was
sort of a interesting question what
happened I mean what actually happened
was that people there was sort of two
camps of people some people said well
it's code we gotta go with the code and
you know and do what happens from that
the other people said let's make a fork
of aetherium and let's let's fork it off
and let's have a fork where we ignore
that transaction we kind of zero it out
we have humans come in and say no we
can't operate just according to code and
may come and sort of say that that's
something we have to as humans we have
to so throw out well so sort of the end
result lost I looked I hadn't looked at
it for a while there was a factor of 10
difference in value between the thing
where where it was yes let's allow the
pure code to operate and let's let's
inject the human so it was sort of an
interesting test case of kind of
running the the financial system is can
you just run it with code or do you
eventually have to have sort of a human
human piece to this now I might I might
say because I would be remiss to not not
mention this I have done the seven out
of work on blockchain and the sort of
idea of cryptocurrencies
and actually one of the issues with
cultural currencies right now is that if
you say I want to do a Bitcoin
transaction it takes ten minutes before
that transaction clears before you can
really say yes I got the money you've
got the money and so on many and for
example the way that banks transfer
money between each other there's a thing
called the Swift Network for example
which translate a CH network right that
transfers money between banks and so if
somebody you know if somebody writes you
a check for ten million dollars which
would be nice
the there's question how does that money
actually get transferred and there's a
whole network that settles those that
that money and and says this bank paid
that money to this person and there's a
whole Civ digital network that that
maintains how that works well and for
smaller amounts of money it works very
fast for things like Bitcoin one of the
issues is but it doesn't work very fast
and part of the reason it doesn't work
fast is because it's maintaining a
ledger where it's a public ledger of
every transaction and in a sense you
have to share like for bitcoins maybe
five thousand different separate places
where there are copies of this ledger
and each one of them has to sort of get
and agree on a copy of the ledger in
order for that transaction to be
ratified and one to go on but that's
kind of silly because if there are two
people who are doing a transaction and
they're you know they're both in Palo
Alto and there are two other people and
they're doing a transaction and they're
in the middle of Rwanda or something the
chances are that those two transactions
will not interact with each other for a
long long time you don't have to have
agreed on both those transactions to be
able to do the other one
so there's a question of can you make a
more distributed form of kind of ledger
or consensus and as it turns out
recently we figured out that using ideas
from our project about fundamental
physics that there is a very good chance
that there's a very cool way to make a
much more decentralized much
or sort of localized form of ledger and
that will will cause it to be the case
that eventually the transaction in Palo
Alto and the transaction at Rwanda have
to be settled together but doesn't have
to happen for a long time
and you can have a consistent framework
where that doesn't happen and it kind of
involves redefining a little bit yet
another level of kind of abstraction for
the idea of value and money and so on
but it's kind of an interesting thing it
probably what will happen is sort of a
form of money in which if you only care
that your bank account is correct to
0.1% accuracy you can know very quickly
how much money you have but if you
really want it to be exactly correct
with no possibility of error it can take
much longer to know that it's correct
and so that's a sort of an uncertainty
principle for money that is kind of a
coming attraction um all right I
unfortunately have to wrap up because I
am supposed to this is my afternoon for
for um talking to people I'm giving a a
technical presentation about physics to
a group that is based in Chile and
although I suspect they'll be people
from other places as well and so I we
talking about much more technical things
here um but um gosh well this is fun for
me so I hope people having fun um lots
of questions here that I didn't get to
I'm sorry and we'll save them up for um
for another time and I look forward to
interacting with you all um in future so
thanks for coming see you later